et du coup on valoir
la partie
bienvenue sur le figaro live on va
analyser ces images ces images à bout de
chat que s'est il passé à abuja c'est la
question que nous allons nous poser
aujourd'hui sujet difficile images
difficiles je suis avec patrick st paul
bonjour patrick merci nana compagne et
rédacteur en chef du service
international on voit aussi suivre ce
qui se passe du côté de l'onu parce que
volodymyr zemsky le président ukrainien
doit s'exprimer après ce qu'il s'est
passé à abuja vous n'hésitez pas à
réagir sur sur les réseaux sociaux à
commenter les vidéos et puis on essaiera
de répondre à vos questions patrick je
vous pose la première peut-être un peu
compliqué parce qu'on n'a pas tous les
éléments mais ce qu'on sait ce qui s'est
passé à bout de chats précisément dans
les dans les semaines qui se sont
écoulées alors on a une idée de
ce qui s'est passé grâce notamment à des
témoignages parce qu'il ya ces images
évidemment il ya aussi des témoignages
qui les accompagnent puisque ça c'est
des gens qui ont été retrouvés dans la
rue dans leur quartier avec leurs
voisins certains membres de leur famille
qu'ils racontent
ce qui s'est passé des employés
municipaux un fossoyeur par exemple
qu'il raconte il a ramassé trois cent
corps d'un goût de chat juste pour
reposer le cadre un peu historique bout
de chat les premières troupes sont
russes sont entrés abuja le 27 février
c'est à dire trois jours après le début
de l'offensive russe à kiev
et elles sont restées jusqu'au 31 mars
donc
ça fait cinq semaines de présence russe
d'ingouchie
c'est une langue du chat et le secteur
faubourg au nord ouest de
de kiev c'est à environ
18 km du centre ville de kiev
en fait dès que les premiers combats ont
commencé le 24 au matin parce qu'il y
avait un point stratégique à côté de
boue de chat qui est
l'aéroport de hausse thomel
l'aéroport antonoff de la ville de ste
mails ou des forces aéroportées russes
ont tenté un assaut pour pénétrer
puisque la stratégie au début c'était de
prendre la ville et de décapiter que le
pouvoir à kiev de prendre la ville en
trois jours et donc la façon la plus
rapide c'était d'arriver par les
aéroports et donc par celui ci qui était
le plus proche du centre ville de kef et
donc
très rapidement il ya une contrefaçon
l'ukrainienne et des combats
qui ont eu lieu entre russes et force
ukrainienne pour parce que en fait on
est au bout quand on est à quand on est
à dire pine beach à tout ça c'est la
même moment où il ya eu le ct
l'épicentre des combats pendant
plusieurs semaines au nord ouest de de
kiev et on est en fait quasiment au bout
de l'avenue de la victoire qui mène à la
place maïdan c'est-à-dire au
centre-ville de kiev donc ça explique
pourquoi les combats acharnés ont eu
lieu à cet endroit précis je rappelle
que vous y étiez pendant presque un mois
c'est ça ouais oui j'ai passé les
quelques jours avant le début de
l'offensive russe et les trois premières
semaines de l'offensive
et donc moi il ya des combats acharnés
mais ce qu'on voit sur ces images
à bout de chat qui est à différencier
aux images qu'on voit de ir pin où ce
sont essentiellement des images de
combats et les gens qui sont visiblement
tuée ou par des frappes
d'artillerie ou par des tirs de missiles
par des bombes à sous-munitions souvent
on
on le voit sur
sur les images par des bombes
incendiaires aussi puisqu'on voit des
corps carbonisés et ça c'est on en voit
aussi à sur les images qui viennent qui
nous viennent de boudhha mais on voit
surtout des gens qui ont été tuées par
balles
des corps qui ont les mains attachées
dans le dos et tout ça indique plutôt
des exécutions
que des morts dans des combats dont qui
en fait une graduation dans qu'en sait
on parle de crimes de guerre c'est que
les règles de la guerre de repas
menés de combats dans l'est dans les
zones où habitent les civils et donc
bombardait des zones où habitait civile
est déjà considéré comme un crime de
guerre comme mario paul par exemple
comme à marioupol comme ailleurs pin
ensuite une radiation au dessus c'est
redondant dans l'horreur du crime de
guerre
torturé cibler des gens les tués par
balles les exécutions sommaires les
mains attachées dans le dos là on est
dans un degré
supérieur de
ces bombardements les millésimes
collatérales des bombardements en fait
et on appelle encore c'est un crime de
guerre on monte encore dans les shales
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya une guerre des
mots en ce moment sur ce qui a pu se
passer à abuja volodia mr evans qui
d'ailleurs on peut voir cette image
regarder
depuis les nations unies où le président
et craignant devrait s'exprimer d'une
minute à l'autre lui il parle de
génocide le président maquereau et le
présent d'haydn parle de crimes de
guerre on entend aussi crimes contre
l'humanité quelles sont les différences
est ici dans ce cas
à quoi on a affaire
la raison pour laquelle volodymyr et
l'ins qui parle d'eux
de génocide e
en
fait il fait référence au discours de
vladimir poutine qui a key qui a précédé
le lancement de son offensive
dans lequel clairement il n'y
le droit d'exister de l'ukraine en tant
que pays et donc en tant que nation donc
la définition du génocide c'est de dire
qu on
va éliminer toute une toute une
population ou une
une race ou une
une religion c'est une religion les gens
et donc pour l'instant évidemment avec
l'échelle la
bcia on parle de 300 morts pour
l'instant on en aura certainement
davantage parce que là on parle des
morts en fait qui ont été collectés dans
trouvé dans les rues et ramener vers des
fosses communes il ya certainement un
tas de morts qu'on n'a pas encore trouvé
qu'ils sont dans l'est dans les caves
dans les appartements où voilà le bilan
risque d'être beaucoup plus lourd que
les 300 encore qu'on a retrouvés jusqu'à
présent donc à cette échelle on peut
évidemment pas parler de génocide où on
est on est pour l'instant c'est pour ça
que les chefs d'état occidentaux parlent
de crime de guerre on est dans le cadre
d'un des raids un crime de guerre je
vous renvoie à cet article regardez qui
est qui est paru qui a paru sur le site
du figaro dans le journal aussi de
margaux ben qui est envoyée spéciale sur
place et je vous lis ces mots parce
qu'ils sont quand même saisissant avant
de retirer de la paix de se retirer de
la périphérie de kiev les russes ont
laissé derrière eux des pièges sur les
cadavres avant de les enterrer il faut
déminer les morts très impressionnant et
assez classique ça se fait dans toutes
les guerres
quand les armes et se retire c'est ça se
faisait à mossoul ça se fait partout on
piège
les maisons les jouets des enfants dans
les chambres et les cadavres aussi c'est
un dessin un peu sordide mais c'est ça
se passe dans tous les conflits donc ça
voilà ça ça rentre pas dans le vraiment
cadre du crime de guerre non plus et
mais bon ça indique un peu
l'intention des forces russes souhaitent
qu'ils sont retirés là on parle de
massacre est-ce que ce qu'on voit à bout
de chat peut changer le cours de la
guerre oui ou non est ce que il y aura
plus de sanctions par exemple
on est déjà en train de prendre les
occidentaux sont en train de discuter de
sanctions supplémentaires pour l'instant
n'est pas encore question
à ce stade de couper totalement
les importations de gaz russe on parle
en revanche de couper les importations
de pétrole et de charbon russe qui voit
qu'une étape supplémentaire dans dans
les sanctions après nombre de massacres
dans l'histoire des guerres ont été
détournés des gars on pense notamment à
celui du marché de markale à sarajevo
qui avait déclenché l'intervention de
l'otan
en bosnie herzégovine
et il y a toujours eu comme
dans tous ces massacres
un
questionnement sur
sur la réalité sur une mise en scène
possible
alors je démens je vois je vois sur
marquez il a fallu d d d d
il ya des doutes pendant des années en
fait est ce que c'était les serbes qui
avaient bombardé réellement ce marché
est ce que c'était les bosniaques qui
s'étaient bombardé eux-mêmes et
finalement l'épreuve ont été établis ou
et la certitude totale établi au bout de
quelques années mais il a fallu des
années pour le prouver et est ce que ce
sera un tournant ça avait été un
tournant pour le marché de markale et
puisqu'on pouvait intervenir face aux
forces serbes qui n'avaient pas le
bouton nucléaire entre les mains là il
ya une grande différence face à la
russie c'est que l'otan n'interviendra
pas militairement contrairement à ce qui
avait été fait en bosnie puis ce qu'on
est face à un président russe qui qui
maîtrise la force nucléaire et
potentiellement on entend dans une
guerre mondiale avec une puissance
nucléaire et on essaie de tout faire les
occidentaux pour pour éviter dans marié
d'en arriver là mais avec des sanctions
en essayant de faire reculer vladimir
poutine grâce à ces sanctions sans
succès pour l'instant il ya beaucoup de
questions sur les sur notre chatte la
véracité de ces vidéos c'est vrai que
les russes disent non non c'est un
montage de toutes pièces des ukrainiens
c'est une mise en scène c'est ce que dit
sergueï lavrov ministre des affaires
étrangères russe et à une guerre de
l'image la main sur sa saga il aggrave
lavrov dit que les cadavres ont été
postées
quelques heures
après la libération de la ville avant
qu'on fait que les forces ukrainienne
autorisé journée c'est entrer dans cette
zone parce qu'il faut savoir cette zone
était inaccessible
pendant cinq semaines au début des
combats il était accessible quand on
était encore un peu d'allant dans dans
les ordres moi par exemple j'ai pu
entrer abuja au début quand il y avait
des combats entre les tchétchènes les
forces tchétchènes de kadirov et les
forces ukrainienne
mais depuis cinq semaines les gens ils
n'avaient plus accès à cette zone en
fait
donc évidemment est une possibilité de
manipulation mais là il existe aussi des
images satellites qui contredisent la
version de sergueï lavrov qui montre que
des décors notamment dans la rue
principale de butch herbe un homme était
bien aux endroits où ils ont été
retrouvés il ya trois semaines elles
n'ont pas il y a deux ou trois jours oui
c'est des images satellites qui sont
parvenus ce matin d'une entreprise
américaine qui a des satellites et qui
explique que les corps sur certaines
photos étaient déjà présents depuis la
mi mars alors que les forces
d'ukrainiens se sont emparés de son
revenu à hyères pin et à bout de chat
seulement la semaine dernière qu
attendre 2 2 et lorsqu'il a aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il va pouvoir dire pour une
fois de plus essayer de convaincre le
monde occidental que l'ukraine a besoin
a besoin de lui
puisqu'ils essaie de faire c'est
depuis le début non seulement
avoir en fait à chaque étape possible
renforcement des sanctions mais aussi de
provoquer
il espère en fait avoir une ce qu'on
appelle une no fly zone une zone
d'exclusion aérienne au-dessus
de l'ukraine pour interdire le ciel
ukrainien aux avions de combat russes
eux
ce que les occidentaux refusent jusqu'à
présent
parce qu'évidemment s'il entre dans ce
dans cette mécanique ils deviennent qu
aux belligérants et donc on entre dans
un élargissement de la guerre ou
potentiellement la pologne peut être
aspiré dans le conflit
mais et lens qui essaient toujours de
pousser un cran plus loin pour faire
comprendre que il faut des sanctions
supplémentaires qui lui faut des armes
en plus ils réclament notamment
maintenant qu'il a eu un certain nombre
d'armes anti chars des missiles
anti-char jaglin et un lot donc fournies
par les britanniques et les américains à
titre gracieux il faut le préciser
aussi des de l'armement anti-aérien pour
pour abattre des hélicoptères et des
avions de combat russes maintenant
ce qu'ils réclament puisque l'ukraine
s'apprête à entrer dans une nouvelle
phase de la guerre en fait est une phase
1 qui était cette offensive raté des
russes sur sur sept ans décapité le
pouvoir ensuite ça c'est ça s'est
prolongée pendant des semaines il ya eu
ces combats qui est maintenant une
nouvelle stratégie des russes
qui est de se concentrer sur l'est du
pays donc le nom bas c'est d'essayer de
prendre le nom basse et de d'avoir ses
gains dans cette région donc c'est une
guerre une nouvelle guerre et c'est une
guerre qui va se mener avec des blindés
et des chars dans ce que réclament les
ukrainiens maintenant ce sont des chars
et des blindés
voilà probablement
volodymyr vegas qui va en plus des
sanctions je ne sais pas s'il le fera
publiquement en tout cas dans ses
conversations avec les chefs d'état
c'est ce qu'ils réclament notamment aux
français ils réclament des chars leclerc
voilà ils réclament des blindés des
chars c'est une première pour zelensky
devant le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
on voit ces images en direct on attend
d'un moment à l'autre on ne sait pas si
c'est un un enregistrement il sera
évidemment en vidéo il est en ukraine
zelensky il était hier à abuja on verra
ça dans un instant
ce que je voulais vous demander aussi c
est ce que les occidentaux font trop
confiance aux images ukrainienne parce
que on a l'impression qu'on est dans ce
camp là et on voit beaucoup de gens qui
se demandent non non ce n'est pas
forcément le cas ce n'est pas forcément
vrai fait qu' une vraie défiance de
plusieurs personnes notamment sur
internet qui des deux mondes non mais on
peut pas croire que les ukrainiens oui
c'est pour ça qu'ils aient des
journalistes terrain et c'est leur
séjour des londoniens les gens ici sont
sur le terrain sont eux aussi très
méfiants parce que il ya une espèce de
syndrome du du charnier de timisoara
donc en roumanie et
crandall permanente d'être manipulés et
et alors
il ya non seulement ces images mais il
ya aussi
rome des témoignages qui sont
recueillies sur le terrain deux voisins
de personnes qui racontent
voilà c'est mon visa on voit un corps
dans des images de boudhha sur lequel
était posé un drap et un vélo et un
voisin raconte
que c'était une de ses voisines qui
avait été dénudée et
probablement violée qui avait été tué
par balle et ledraa été posée sur son
corps et un cycliste est passée et a
posé le vélo pour que le drame ne
s'envolent pas et voilà il ya tout un
tas de témoignages comme ça qui qui qui
attestent les faits qui raconte les
circonstances dans lesquelles les décors
qu'on retrouve comme ça et voilà comment
ces personnes ont été tuées en réalité
qui mène l enquête alors on sait que
l'union européenne a décidé qu'elle
voulait se coordonner avec les
ukrainiens pour mener les enquêtes
comment ça va se passer à ce qu'ils
seront totalement indépendant est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir déplacer à ce qu'on
ait une idée de comment ça peut se
passer du temps que ça peut prendre
imagine que selon des enquêteurs qui
sont sur le terrain déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines des critères
internationaux
là le parquet antiterroriste française
s'est saisie de 2
de certains cas notamment à bout de
chats et
le ministère français de la justice a
proposé une assistante d'envoyer des
enquêteurs
supplémentaire pour épauler les
enquêteurs ukrainiens tout ça se fait
sous la houlette pour l'instant de la
procureure générale l'ukrainienne qui
depuis le début de la guerre en quête et
à des équipes qui enquête sur les sur
les crimes qui ont été menées ensuite si
on arrive à un stade où il ya une
enquête internationale un tribunal
international spécial qui est monté pour
l'ukraine comme ça avait été le cas en
bosnie en ex yougoslavie
par exemple là ce sera sur sous sous
sous l'autorité de ce que les enquêteurs
qui enquêtent pour ce tribunal sont sous
l'autorité de ce tribunal en fait le la
justice ukrainienne à ce moment là
risquent de se retrouver dessaisi du
dossier et transmettra les éléments
qu'elle a pu recueillir aux enquêteurs
internationaux du tribunal spécial qui
aurait été créé pour l'ukraine mais à ce
stade on n'en est pas là mais c'est une
enquête qui va être très longue certes
pour l'instant ce qu'on a ce sont des
indices il ya des médecins légistes qui
vont venir et qui vont analyser les
corps pour savoir comment ils ont été
tués il des autopsies vont être menées
mais ce qu'on sait pas ce qu'on sait
déjà par exemple si on parlait au début
de les images de ce charnier convoyer
qui contiendrait quelques centaines de
corps en pensant que les russes avaient
fait un charrier un charnier dans lequel
il avait
me un certain nombre de victimes est en
fait par des témoignages recueillis par
des journalistes à abuja on sait que
c'est le fossoyeur du cimetière de
debout de chars qui sur ordre de la
municipalité et
à a creusé un certain nombre de
charniers
en ville et
pour enfouir ces corps parce que pour
pour des raisons sanitaires tout
simplement je vous rappelle qu'on attend
toujours l'intervention de volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien devant
devant l'onu j'ai une remarque sur sûr
youtube de flamme qui nous disent il ya
génocide les nations autres que les pays
impliqués sont obligés d'intervenir de
manière militaire est peut-être là le
but de zelensky de dire génocide de ce
mot là qui est très important qui est
marquant
oui mais je pense et je suis pas sûr que
ce soit pour provoquer une intervention
internationale et je pense qu'il a bien
compris qu'il y aurait pas
d'intervention à ce stade que pour pour
les occidentaux certainement bien qu'ils
ne le disent pas publiquement
parce que ça a été le cas en ciel en
appareils lignes rouges sur
l'utilisation du chimique ou ou du
bactériologiques et en fait ces lignes
rouges barack obama ne l'a jamais fait
respectez donc on évite de paille ligne
rouge on sait que voilà dans la tête des
autres qui a en tout cas des plans qui
sont
qui sont établis de réponse à l'emploi
d'armes chimiques ou bactériologiques à
l'emploi d'armes nucléaires et donc
voilà ça c'est un peu les lignes rouges
après parler de génocide je pensais
aussi une façon pour volodymyr zaleski
de dire que l'ukraine est dans un combat
pour sa survie c'est une façon pour lui
gagner de galvaniser son peuple willy à
l'opinion internationale
il y a aussi le message à l'adresse de
sa population
le message pour les ukrainiens c on se
bat pour notre survie et c'est aussi un
peu le message qu'il veut faire passer
aux occidentaux on se bat pour notre
survie donc donnez nous des armes
aidez nous
augmenter les sanctions mais je pense
qu'il a tout de même conscience à ce
stade qu'il n'y aura pas d'intervention
internationale pour pour venir au
secours des ukrainiens on rappelle que
la russie est membre du conseil de
sécurité permanents de l'onu c'est à
dire que là les russes sont obligés de
recevoir la parole de zelensky si j'ose
dire en pleine figure qui va a parlé à
l'ambassadeur de de russie aux nations
unies c'est ce sont les britanniques qui
préside en ce moment ce conseil de
sécurité qui ont et qui ont validé cette
décision c'est un geste fort ça
peut-être c'est une présidence tournante
donc ce sont les britanniques qui fixe
les règles du jeu puisque c'est eux qui
préside en ce moment le conseil de
sécurité donc ils ont non seulement
choisi de donner la parole
de mener la contradiction aux russes qui
avaient saisi le conseil de sécurité
pour dire qu'il s'agissait de
manipulation et de fausses preuves et
donc on aura non seulement
l'intervention du président ukrainien
mais aussi
les français les britanniques et
les américains le secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken doit s'exprimer qu'ils
ont l'intention de présenter un certain
nombre de preuves qui contredisent la
version russe alors ses preuves se sont
lesquelles ce sont des îles c'est à dire
qu'il ya des militaires ou des forces
spéciales ou des renseignements sur
place comment ce qu'il s'agit
essentiellement des images satellites
que
qui était évoqué tout à l'heure alors
une autre question qu'on peut se poser
vladimir poutine que risque-t-il parle
beaucoup du crime du crime de guerre est
ce que il peut être inquiété
pour qu'ils soient inquiétés il faut
pouvoir prouver qu'il a donné un ordre
alors justement est-ce que si on si on
résume parce que c'est pas forcément
toujours simple est ce que on doit
savoir si ce sont des actes perpétrés
par des soldats de manière individuelle
ce qui s'est passé à bout de chat ou est
ce que c'est une autre qui vient d'en
haut et là ça changerait tout
si un ordre venait d'en haut ça changera
tout mais pour broder des exactions de
cette nature en général c'est très
difficile même s'il ya pu y avoir un
ordre qui vient d'en haut de 2 d'établir
la chaîne de commandement en revanche ce
qu'on sait c'est que en fait ce qui se
passe
dans dans ce cas deux bouts de chasse et
des exactions et qui sont visiblement
assez répandue c'est à une échelle qui
calme
assez assez fort parce que il ya environ
trois cent corps qui ont été tuées par
balles
un certain nombre de corps porte des
traces de torture un certain nombre de
femmes ont été violées et aussi dans le
papier de l'article de margaux men paru
ce matin elle fait témoigner
des psychologues
qui traite des femmes qui ont été
violées et qui font un récit absolument
épouvantable de ce qui se passe et de
l'attitude des soldats russes qui après
avoir tué les hommes se saoulent
violent les femmes parfois devant les
enfants
à plusieurs avec des soldats de tous les
âges si vous leur élection avec des
dents qui sont cassé à coups de crosse
on parle de choses extrêmement violente
certaines d'entre elles sont exécutées
ensuite d'autres survivent
miraculeusement mais ça aussi ce sont
des crimes de guerre et les crimes de
guerre sont une arme qui est utilisé par
les russes dans tous les conflits où
elle où elles mènent des guerres ça a
été le cas en tchétchénie ça a été le
cas en afghanistan ça a été le cas en
syrie et c'est une arme qui est fait
pour faire pour pour casser totalement
le moral d'une population pour que la
population baisse les bras et cesse de
se battre or les ukrainiens continuent
de se battre et et donc on a essayé de
leur casser le moral en utilisant ses
armes alors est-ce que des ordres
viennent d'en haut probablement non en
revanche c'est quelque chose qui est
inscrit dans la culture de l'armée russe
partout où elle passe depuis des
décennies et donc ccc c'est une c ce
sont des manières de l'armée russe qui
sont répandues et qui se sont et qui ont
prospéré dans tous les conflits où
l'armée russe a été impliqué et
l'article de marc gaubert ce matin il
est franc il prend aux tripes d'abord le
matin ou l'après midi les soldats
vérifier qu'ils vivaient dans les
maisons puis il revenait le soir tu es
les éventuelles sommes du foyer pied de
l'argent et les objets précieux ils
mangeaient et buvaient ce qu'ils
trouvaient dans la maison et quand il
était saoul il violait les filles et les
femmes même en présence d'enfants les
russes sont en train de se retirer on a
l'impression de deux cuves pourquoi à ce
moment là c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas
l'intention de s'arrêter dans ce cas
il se retire de kiev position en train
de reculer disons ils se sont totalement
retiré quasiment totalement retirés de
cap les les
renseignements américains disent qu'il
reste à peu près un tiers des forces qui
étaient présentes qui sont en train de
se retirer il se retira une grande
vitesse en allant vers la frontière
biélorusse
tout simplement parce qu'ils ont perdu
la guerre de kiev et qu' ils ont compris
que kiev ne serait pas prenable d'où
cette retraite et ce changement de
stratégie et cette nouvelle guerre qui
va commencer dans le donbass une
question sur sur youtube at on des
journalistes du figaro sur place sont
des journalistes d'autres médias qui
donnent de l'information au figaro
comment vous organisez au service
international expliquait nous eh bien on
a trois journalistes quatre journalistes
sur le terrain actuellement nous avons
une
journaliste pigiste qui couvrent pour
nous l'ukraine depuis deux ans et qui
était avant notre correspondante à kiev
et qui se replier à lviv
nous avons marre goven
donc y est
journaliste service international du
film à paris et qui est acquis avant ce
moment qu'ils étaient à
hyères ping et butch à
tous ces derniers jours c'est ce que
c'est on parle c'est ma salle à sa vie
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ça
fait des jours que margot ben avec la
photographe véronique de viguerie avec
laquelle elle travaille enquête sur sur
ce qui se passe dans ces zones et
attendent de pouvoir entrer et sont
entrés de façon plus ou moins ponctuels
dans butch adam et repine s'accueillir
pin s'est ouvert avant boudchar parce
que les russes se sont de retiers
retirer ou ont été repoussés par les
forces ukrainienne dire pin avant bout
de chat donc l appel ont pu entrer à
irbine depuis quatre ou cinq jours
ensuite elles sont entrées à bout de
chapuis aoste au mail et donc peu à peu
tous les quartiers où les où les russes
étaient on peut vraiment on peut voir
cette carte envoie au nord de au
nord-ouest de kiev voilà c'est dit un
peu plus loin avant l'aéroport de
stockholm voilà donc ça c'était au nord
ouest il ya un autre front qui se trouve
au nord-est
à brovary qui est à peu près 15 km du
centre ville de kiev et
là c'était plus vraiment des combats à
l'artillerie les avec des
les russes et les ukrainiens qui
reprenait du terrain un peu chaque jour
donc c'était pas des combats statique
donc les morts qui ont
dans cette région là sont plus des morts
par caen était tué par des tirs
d'artillerie est ce qui différencie en
fait la zone de brovary avec la zone de
boudhha érotomane cecab ou de chats
errants semaine les forces russes
étaient présentes de façon statique
pendant cinq semaines et la voilà elle
tenait en fait cette cette zone est donc
c'est et on voit ce qui se passe dans
une zone qui est complètement tenus par
les russes et c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui est très très choquant
quand on voit la façon dont ils se sont
comportés les hommes
des forces russes sur place parce que
les témoignages parlent
de torture de
de viols des exécutions sommaires
de
en fait les soldats russes faisait
irruption dans une maison réclamer de la
nourriture piller les maisons
réclamé à boire et ensuite pour décider
de la vie ou de la mort des résidents de
la maison en fait vérifier les messages
que pour tes leur téléphone portable et
donc s'il y avait un message déplaisants
à l'égard des forces russes souvent
c'était très mauvais pour les pour les
habitants de la maison
s'il ya des informations qui ont été
transmises par exemple à des soldats
ukrainiens qui sont de nature militaire
là c'était une exécution immédiate voilà
donc en fait les soldes à entrer dans
les maisons avait droit de vie ou de
mort de viols de tortures sur sur les
habitants des maisons on en a déjà un
peu parlé mais beaucoup de questions
là-dessus avec marianne qui nous dit
honnêtement condamné un président qui a
l'armé nucléaire on sait très bien que
c'est impossible est-ce que ce que veut
faire volodymyr zelensky on imagine
essayer de faire condamner poutine à
terme ont en tout cas d'essayer de le
faire reculer c'est voué à l'échec parce
que la meilleure poutine à l'armé
nucléaire
c'est voué à l'échec tant qu'il est au
pouvoir mais on a vu un certain nombre
de pays un certain de nos guerres ou
les présidents en place ne restez pas
éternellement en place si un jour
pour l'instant c'est pas du tout le
la question de la situation interne fait
que le pouvoir de vladimir poutine pour
l'instant et il est pas en danger mais
selon la tournure que prendront les
évènements selon la tournure que prendra
cette guerre il n'est pas impossible
qu'un jour un soulèvement de l'armée ou
du fsb des renseignements
russe contre vladimir poutine et qu'ils
ne détiennent que le pouvoir est à ce
moment là
il pourrait être traduit devant la
justice internationale
quelle est la position de la france très
clairement depuis deux jours depuis 48
heures depuis qu'on voit ces images à
abuja est ce que ça a pu faire changer
de cap
la diplomatie française
non elle reste toujours sur la même
carte c'est à dire de d'augmenter
graduellement les sanctions à chaque
fois que l'on découvre que qu'en fait il
ya une graduation dans dans ce que font
les forces russes sur le terrain donc là
il
on a franchi un cap
avec ses révélations sur ces massacres
les faux la position de la france est
qu'il faut franchir un nouveau cap dans
les sanctions et un cap significatif
et si effectivement on cesse les
importations de gaz et de pétrole russe
ce sera un cap assez significatif mais
qui fera mal au régime
j'ai une autre question de ali sur
youtube il nous dit sans tuer des
syriens avant des tchétchènes sont pas
été affectés par les sanctions il n'y a
rien à faire contre les russes on a
l'impression
ce que je disais à l'instant que tant
que la dîmière poutine
est au pouvoir il n'y a rien à faire non
là il ya une différence je pense dans
l'attitude du monde sait que cette
guerre a lieu en europe à nos portes et
donc nous touche de plus près mais on
voit bien à quel point c'est difficile
voilà deux contres et vladimir poutine
puisque effectivement c'est une
puissance nucléaire avec
on est dans un risque de guerre mondiale
et de guerre nucléaire merci patrick st
paul d'avoir été avec moi rédacteur en
chef internationale au figaro on va
attendre on va suivre à l'onu ce qui va
se passer avec volodymyr zelensky qui
doit qui doit s'exprimer on laisse ces
images et puis on écoute vladimir
zelensky qui devra arriver d'un instant
à l'autre on ne sait pas encore si c'est
dû différer si ce sera en direct mais le
président ukrainien doit s'exprimer
devant le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies
[Musique]
pour un autre
à cet
égard
et ces acteurs
du web qui
occupe et je n'ai pas de
souci avec
ma fille m'a
dit
les deux hommes
et
un
mixeur cette
action est une
démocratie
tout comme edwin truman
exactes
de sa mort
croix
de
chemin dans les bois on va dans
la
poche
des deux boîtes noires des
deux roues et
chaouchi
like all night
et
continue de rachat walgreen into salle
otello
tds racing street food and is here is
going to
be
continued airs de country will be on rit
on pleure
on a tous une choix grèce ce qui oblige
elle note en international la note
interne à son institution united nations
nations
et fm cerise nos derniers nient tout est
immédiate les îles veille ou un tshirt
masri restore émis depuis des u16 damas
beyrouth en 2002 des soldats devaient
vite et où des
représentants
des
cff
b
vide
greniers people
watch
d'ici
là
le panneau
des offres
françaises
non
grâce
à
des offres pis ma vie comme dans
les
îles privées mais je ne m'interdis
de francs quant aux méthodes
mixtes et les difficultés du prêt à tout
nutrition
et de maintenant au tour à
tour
a dit moin rachat l'année grâce à une
sorte
de twitter to
guy
[Musique]
ritchie
à
10h12
biz green it is your own it is in the
world speaks el fani outcry à ski vers
images tous watch death schwarz video
with one more bennett audio times david
la dette oui à
adhérer aux offres business
[Applaudissements]
chose quand même
il a peur de tout et technique